yeah this weekend well it's gonna be a
big one for James Corden he is pulling
out all the stops for his show that will
follow Stephen Colbert right after Super
Bowl 50 and James even has his own
adorable parents covering the big game
Graham how cute is that and we got the
scoop talking to both generations of
coordinates what do you make of American
football I just don't understand it we
went to watch one in London and the
nicest bit for me was when I went into
the locker rooms at the end we were like
well who could we send as a
representative and we thought well let's
send to people who know nothing about
the NFL okay you gotta be the coolest
parents ever James dad Malcolm can belt
out Coldplay on the sax and mom are is
totally no-frills they didn't send you
with a big glam team or anything like
that this is the tenth time we've
appeared on CBS no makeup give you
makeup no nothing
Malcolm and Mark drop by a special
edition of Corden's Late Late Show after
the Super Bowl on CBS along with a very
special carpool karaoke guest John right
I know
come on carpool karaoke John yeah it
might be one of my favorites cause you
could do two hours and you'd still be
playing hits